百分之八十的人都在重複昨天做的事
五年之内很难有什么变化
但是如果你能转换一些思维
你的生活将会换人一心
甚至还有一部分人
收入会在很多案的时间的分辈
这个区别就是任务思维后产品思维
任务思维是什么呢?任务思维是完成
是交财
产品思维是书明了
我们任务思维是什么?就是老板说
你要完成这个任务
那我就完成了
完成完以后拿钱就财
对吧
然后这个时候你的结果清零
所以你做的事叫号财
大概产品思维是什么呢?
是我做完这个事情
我能不能以后反复去使用
能不能处理行员的标击
能不能在很能看着之后说
挖我这个太棒了
然后可以给我带来更多的机会
所以这个时候你做的那个产品
其实是资产
所以各位
任务思维的本质是用时间去换仇劳
但是产品思维是把你的能力
转化成资产
而且当你从任务思维转化成产品思维之后
它会激发你的三大增长引擎
首先第一个就有个人品牌
有当你任真做一件事情的时候
比如说这个产品做的靠口
这个人是靠口的
就会给你带来更多的机会
这是最简单的给我们个人生值的方法之意
第二个的话就是你做这个产品
它的生用周期更长
比如说你的一篇文章
一个作品在请您之后
还会持续给你带来收益
比如说在国庆节之前
我三年前写的价值信法
还在想一
你的作品级越后
给你带的收益和影响力就越大
第三个其实是最重要的
就是你个人的拥有感
因为你是做任务的
任务完成的完成了
但是你做产品的
这是关乎你的脸面
这是关乎你自己
你在做自己的东西
你不再是一个执行者
而是一个创造者
所以你会有无情的内区力
它是打扮你内耗的
打扮你这种拖延的
让你充满自己的最好的解药
但是我们到底该怎么做呢
给大家介绍几个方法
首先第一个就是
尽可能让你过去的所有工作
产品化
就想一想你过去做的事情
是不是可以做话成一个产品
它是给谁用的
在什么场景下使用
解决了它的什么问题
如果你在打扮的话
能打扮的话
如果是60%的话
你能不能把它做成90%
这是第一件事情
第二件事情
就是给自己先利自己的作品
资料库
你像我个人就会在人都身里面
给我的每一个作品有一个标号
什么事件做了什么产品
解决了什么样的问题
在什么背影下做的
然后我个人感觉
打扮怎么样
对了
如果我们要从够
怎么把它可以看到
我还会有从够的标签
然后
这个的话
会给你带来了
资源
资料
又你未来从这个技术
从这个技术上
可以有无穷的这种创造力
同时会让你的知识结果化
和体制化
第三件事情是非常重要的
当你做完了以后
一定要把它发出去
比如说是你的朋友圈
或者是一个公开的网络
注意这件事很重要
叫做
Biu的音popic
就是让更多的人看到
增加你的信音
表面底
这是增加你个人品牌的第一步
所以各位
好好想象
这句话
工作的终点
不是完成
你实际上是在做一件
自己愿意属民的作品